Every time you import a texture into UE5, that texture will have some type of compression applied to it, unless you specifically tell the engine not to.
By default, textures are going to be compressed to either DTX1 or DTX5.
Now, DTX just stands for DirectX, and this is the format that Unreal will convert any texture you import into the engine for you automatically behind the scenes.
The 1 signifies that this particular texture does not have alpha information, while the 5 signifies that it does.
The other thing the engine will do for you is any normal map you have brought in will be automatically compressed to normal map.
However, other textures will require that you manually adjust the texture compression settings.
Now, one of the cool things that I like about the texture compression options is that they're non-destructive, and they're very, very quick to show the end result.
Now, oftentimes, you might have a texture, and maybe default doesn't give you exactly what you want, and you maybe select, I don't know, grayscale, or displacement, or HDR, and that works.
If you're unsure that the texture compression method that you've selected is the correct one, keep this in mind.
If that texture compression method does what you want, and the artwork looks exactly how you need it, and there are no performance issues, then that is the method that you can go with.
I highly encourage everybody to experiment with different compression settings, so that they can understand exactly what they do, and how they can be utilized inside of your individual projects.